[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute richtig
schöne festliche Bayram bzw 8 Kekse
dieses Wort dass ich seit wievielter
haben wir dann drei haben wir 7 oder 8
seitdem immer noch nicht aussprechen
kann auf jeden Fall machen wir heute
prägekekse also Kekse aus zartem Vanille
Mürbeteig die geprägt sind mit schönen
Mustern und ich mache jetzt erstmal
meine
lieblings Standard Mürbeteig viele
machen Mürbeteig mit ganz kalter Butter
das ist auch richtig auch bei bestimmten
Rezepten ist es auf jeden Fall
vorteilhaft aber bei meinem Keksrezept
muss die Butter weich sein also einfach
zwei Stunden oder drei Stunden vorher
aus dem Kühlschrank nehmen und dann wird
sie zusammen mit Zucker eine richtig
guten Prise Salz der hier nämlich noch
mal den süßen Geschmack und
Vanilleextrakt richtig schön cremig
geschlagen ich mache das mit der
Küchenmaschine aber ihr könnt das auch
irgendwie mit einem Handrührgerät machen
das funktioniert auch aber mit der
Küchenmaschine geht einfach so ein
bisschen fluffiger und Vanille gibt hier
den ganzen Geschmack daher darf die
nicht fehlen und falls ihr euch fragt wo
stehen die ganz genau die schreibe ich
euch wie immer hier unten in die Infobox
und ich fange jetzt an das ganze so zwei
drei Minuten zu schlagen
[Musik]
jetzt gucken wir uns mal die Butter
Zuckermasse an sie ist richtig schön
hell cremig geworden genauso muss sie
sein das macht nämlich später was mit
der Konsistenz der Kekse genauso wie ein
Ei das hat auch was mit der Konsistenz
zu tun wenn ihr das ganze allerdings
ohne Ei zubereiten möchtet dann könntet
ihr stattdessen auch so ein bisschen mit
Milch kompensieren ist aber nicht das
gleiche Ergebnis nur es würde notfalls
auch gehen das würde ich jetzt nur noch
ganz kurz unter und anschließend gebe
ich schon mal Backpulver hier zum Mehl
und das könnt ihr vorab so ein bisschen
verrühren ihr müsst es jetzt eigentlich
nicht sieben aber ich mache das trotzdem
weil je nach Lagerung kann ja sein dass
du so ein bisschen klüppchen entstanden
sind und so umgehe ich das einfach dass
da irgendwie noch klümchen festgesetzt
sind im Teig das ganze wird dann einfach
nur noch verrückt ein bisschen glatter
Teig entsteht
[Musik]
zuerst werdet ihr das Gefühl haben dass
du viel zu viel Mehl für den Teig aber
nach wenigen Sekunden werdet ihr merken
es ist genau perfekt nur die
Ärmel hochkrempeln hier und der Teig der
ist so richtig weich aber fest also man
kann es gar nicht richtig beschreiben
der ist einfach richtig richtig gut den
nehme ich mir jetzt einmal raus ich habe
jetzt keine Frischhaltefolie mehr da
aber ich habe jetzt hier noch ein
Gefrierbeutel da lege ich meinen Tag
jetzt einfach rein hier flacher ihr ihn
andrückt desto besser kühlt er durch
weil die Masse dann natürlich nicht so
dick ist daher werde ich ihn jetzt
richtig flach ausbreiten und dann für 30
Minuten in den Kühlschrank legen wenn
ihr es natürlich dicker lass dann
braucht der Teig auch gerne mal eine
Stunde oder einen Tag daher richtig
schön flach dann spart ihr euch auch
Zeit andersrum im Umkehrschluss könnt
ihr das auch irgendwie den Tag vorher
vorbereiten oder zwei drei Tage und dann
einfach im Kühlschrank lagern das ist
nämlich ein richtig schöner entspannter
Teig der ist richtig pflegeleicht
[Musik]
so nach der Kühlzeit konnten sich auch
die Zuckerkristalle im Teig schön
auflösen ich nehme den Teig jetzt einmal
raus es ist ein bisschen bröckelig das
ist ganz normal ihr könnt jetzt einfach
mit der Handwärme noch mal so ein
bisschen geschmeidig kneten aber auch
nur so kurz wie notwendig und dann wird
der noch mal schön ausgerollt
so den Teig habe ich jetzt echt nur so
15 20 Sekunden zusammen geknetet und
jetzt wird er hier auf der Silikonmatte
einfach nur noch ausgerollt ich nehme
jetzt dafür mein ausrollstab damit ich
einfach gleichmäßig in gleichmäßig
dicken Teig habe und so weiß ich auch
dass alle Kekse gleichzeitig im Ofen gar
werden und nicht die einen dann
irgendwie zu dünn sind und dadurch zu
trocken werden das sind ja meistens
Sachen von einer halben Minute oder eine
Minute das dann Kekse wirklich trocken
und drücke werden und dadurch dass jetzt
hier viel Butter drin haben sollte das
eigentlich jetzt kein trockener Teig
sein sondern im Gegenteil richtig
leckerer selbstgemachter Keksteig so und
ich habe jetzt hier die Abstandsringe
sechs Millimeter drauf drei finde ich
doch ein bisschen zu dünn und 10 mm
finde ich persönlich zu dick da habe ich
mich jetzt für 6 mm entschieden genau
das wird das einfach ausgerollt und dann
zeige ich euch was für coole Ausstecher
wir haben denn ich muss euch sagen in
den letzten Jahren also wir hatten immer
seit wir unseren Onlineshop geöffnet
haben immer Ramadan Specials und dieses
Jahr haben wir einfach noch viel mehr
geschafft als die letzten Jahre wir
haben zuletzt ist ja immer die Datteln
gehabt die Pistazien Oskar sie an Tape
und ähm genau
[Musik]
ist das nicht süß ich feier diese
Ausstecher ich werde sie euch auf jeden
Fall in die Infobox verlinken damit ihr
sie noch rechtzeitig habt weil das
Geniale ist dieses Rezept ne das ist so
entspannt ihr könnt sogar die Kekse
machen und zwei Wochen in einer Keksdose
lagern und sie schmecken dann nicht alt
oder so die bleiben einfach oh das sieht
so schön aus ich bin so begeistert sie
bleiben einfach schön mürbe im Gegenteil
je mehr Tage ihr sie zugepackt in einer
vorratshausen umso mehr Bar werden sie
und dann haben wir verschiedenste Motive
und ihr könnt auch einfach hier dieses
diesen großen Ausstecher der den Teil
komplett durch einfach auf dem Teig
liegen lassen weil das hilft euch noch
mal dass ihr dann auch nicht verrutscht
und das ist einfach
ich sag's euch das ist das ist das Ding
dieses Jahr ich mache nur noch solche
Kekse wann sind sie super unaufwendig ne
so ich mache mal weiter hier und dann
kommen sie bei mir aufs Backblech da
habe ich schon Backpapier und drunter
und ich nehme da am besten zur Hilfe
immer eine Winkelpalette dann kann ich
immer schön unten drunter gehen ohne mir
was kaputt zu machen
[Musik]
den überschüssigen Teig jetzt noch mal
ganz kurz zusammenkneten ihr werdet
merken dass wenn ihr euch Zeit lasst
oder je nachdem wie warm es auch ist
wenn man hier die ganzen Lichter an dass
der Teig schon sehr weich wird und
grundsätzlich ob ihr euch Zeit lasst
oder nicht ist es ganz ganz wichtig
damit ihr auch die Form beibehaltet dass
ihr euer Blech jetzt noch mal für 10 bis
15 Minuten in den Kühlschrank gibt
solange könnt ihr auf den Ofen vorheizen
und auch schon mal den nächsten Tag
ausstechen falls ihr kein Platz habt im
Kühlschrank also bei mir ist es so ich
habe ja dieses Blech das verlinke ich
euch auch gerne in die Infobox da kann
ich die Seiten hier einfach reinfahren
und dann habe ich sogar Platz bei mir im
kleinen Kühlschrank und wenn ihr kein
Platz habt dann könnt ihr das auch
irgendwie so um switchen dass ihr das
auf Teller legt aber unbedingt ein
Backpapier und runter weil sonst bekommt
ihr die Kekse vom Teller nicht mehr ab
das wäre noch so mein Tipp aber wie
gesagt diese Kühlzeit dürft ihr nicht
außer Acht lassen weil was passiert
sonst die Butter ist weich und alles ver
schmilzt irgendwie ineinander und ihr
habt nichts mehr von einem Form und das
wäre echt schade und das kann man mit
diesem kleinen und einfachen Trick
umgehen und ich mache in der
Zwischenzeit mein restlichen Teig fertig
und dann sehen wir uns nach dem Backen
wieder
[Musik]
also ich finde die Kekse können sich
sehen lassen sie haben bei 190 Grad
Ober- und Unterhitze 12 Minuten
gebraucht achtet bitte darauf dass Sie
nicht zu dunkel werden sie sollen
richtig schön goldbraun backen zu dunkel
damit sie einfach zu trocken daher
können sie auch ruhig hell bleiben also
sind sie echt perfekt und wie gesagt sie
halten wirklich wochenlang ihr könnt sie
ganz entspannt vorbereiten ihr könnt sie
verschenken in Kaffee trinken einfach so
essen einfach schön einfach schick also
macht sie gerne nach verlinke euch alles
Wichtige und in der Infobox und dann
sehen wir uns hoffentlich auch beim
nächsten Rezept tschüss
[Musik]